♪ ♪ ♪
- Une fête au grand air;
des centaines d'étudiants se
retrouvent pour l'une des
dernières soirées de l'été.
Qui dit festivités, dit aussi
parfois abus. Mais un groupe
presque entièrement composé de
femmes se mobilisent pour les
éliminer.
ALEXANDRINE BEAUVAIS LAMOUREUX,
cofondatrice Scène et Sauve
- Scène et sauve est là ce soir
pour prévenir les violences vioà
caractère sexuel. Les gens
ne savent pas vers qui se
référer s'il arrive quelque
chose. Donc, le but de Scene et
Sauve, c'est de vraiment être
la référpersonnes
ressources.
- L'organisme à but non lucratif
"Scène et Sauve" sensibilise les
participants dès leur arrivée.
MARIELOU LÉGER, sentinelle
t Sauve
- Donc, si jamais tu es victime,
qu'il y a moins de quoi que ce
soit, il va y avoir toujours
quelqu'un qui est ici au
kiosque.
- Si une personne vit du
harcèlement, comme porte de
sortie, elle peut toujours se
tourner vers une de leurs
sentinelles.
Ce soir, 11 sentinelles
parcourent la piste de danse et
les alentours.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Allô, tout va bien pour vous?
- Elles font discrètementplusiet
la soirée.
- On y va... soit ça peut être à
des moments où des gens nous ont
interpellé : "Ah, telle
personne, je suis moins à
l'aise. Elle comprend moins mes
limites."
- Il y a encore un gars qui est
posté à l'entrée?
- Oui, un gars à l'entrée et un
gars à la sortie.
- Elles font appel aux gardes de
sécurité advenant une situation
plus sérieuse, ou dirigent
les victimes vers les
professionnels qualifiés.
Une chose est sûre : leur
présence rend plusieurs
participantes à l
- Ce genre de soirée où
ils prévoient ce genre de chose,
c'est tellement plus rassurant
pour nous.
- Ils once dans tous
les événements. Dès qu'il y a de
l'alcool, la consommation est
impliquée, hommes et femmes
mélangés, il y a toujours
quelque chose qui se passe.
- Depuis mars, l'équipe est de
plus en plus présente dans
les événements étudiants.
Elle a été approchée pour
u HEC Montréal en mai
dernier et ses services sont
demandés pendant
les initiations.
Les sentinelles sont des
bénévoles. Elles étudient dans
des domaines d'intervention
comme en psychologie et en
sciences infirmières.
- Ce n'est pas encore arrivé des
soirées où on était présente et
qu'il n'y a pas eu de gens qui
ont subi du harcèlement sexuel,
mais on va aussi agir, par
exemple avec les personnes qui
sont intoxiquées, que ce soit à
l'alcool, que ce soit à diverses
drogues récréatives,
- Plus d'une personnes sur trois
qui étudie ou travaille dans
les universités du Québec a déjà
vécu une forme de violence
sexuelle, selon une étude de
2017.
JASMIN PETIT, directeur du
développement des affaires
- C'est mieux de faire quelque
chose que de rien faire. Puis
je pense qu'en s'alliant avec
Scène et Sauve on fait une
action. Puis, oui, c'est
peut-être pas parfait. Oui,
c'est le début d'un changement,
mais il faut le faire ce
changement là.
- La soirée tire à sa fin.
Scène et Sauve dit avoir déjà
offert du soutien à plusieurs
participantes.
- Ce soir, par exet
surtout des témoins qui sont
venus nous relater des
événements qui se sont passés
sur la piste de danse.
- L'organisme esp jour
ses services deviendront
inutiles, mais force lui est
d'admettre qu'elle devra encore
patienter.
Ici Chaoulin,
Radio-Canada, Mon